[Music]
the world is stressful these days and
you know what
sometimes to survive
i just gotta cut loose and give in to
some of my more
indecent desires you know what i'm
talking about tarek i do so come along
while we give you a glimpse of what
we're into when no one's watching in a
segment we call guilty pleasures
[Music]
i use the same knife to get the peanut
butter and the jelly
[Music]
i haven't paid attention to an airline
safety presentation in 15 years
[Music]
you know that linen robe that was
hanging on the back of the door in your
bathroom when i came over for dinner i
used it to dry my hands
and my face
[Music]
i never turn off my phone when i'm in
church because i love to make a scene
[Music]
i feel bad about killing an ant but i
would eat a beautiful little baby lamb
right now no questions asked
[Music]
i carry an important looking briefcase
everywhere i go but the only thing
inside it is snacks
[Applause]
[Music]
i talked to the uber driver from the
moment i get in the car to the moment i
get out
[Applause]
i put sugar and salt on my grits because
i deserve both
[Music]
i made the rhyme did the crime smelt it
and dealt it it was all me
amber i'm sorry no you're not no i am
not this has been guilty pleasures
[Applause]
[Music]
you